welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Loki season two seems to be on
track for releasing on Disney plus
sometime this summer and while we are
still waiting on a full trailer new
Disney plus promos are releasing showing
Fuller wider shots of some particularly
cryptic images from the trailer that I
saw in d23 that actually recontextualize
what we can expect from this new season
the guanamania post credit scene
confirmed that Loki and Mobius will be
on a hunt through time for Victor timely
a hunt that will take them back to 1901
but now these new promo shots confirm
that they will be doing so while going
rogue from the TVA Loki will be at war
with TVA agents perhaps because this DBA
has shown its True Colors crypted by the
influence of the gang Dynasty so let's
break down everything new we've learned
and a reminder to subscribe to our new
channel the Deep dive where I did an
insane analysis of Loki season 1 and
this Sunday night I'll be doing a live
stream of The Last of Us finale okay the
first new shot from Loki season 2 is
this one of Loki using the pruning stick
to erase some Euro wall of the three
time Keepers in the sacred timeline now
I've seen this shot before but it's a
bigger that now and you can see a lot
more in it we saw murals like this in
the courtroom and the TVA but this is a
new set based on the severed time keeper
head I want to say it's not too far from
the elevators that lead down to the
timekeeper chamber on the tva's legal
level not that far from rensselaer's
office but we also know that not far
from legal is an exterior Veranda
walkway that looks out over the TVA this
is where Mobius escorted Loki when he
was still in his prisoner jumpsuit after
he was arraigned in front of rensslayer
in episode one that walkway was actually
based on the forgive my pronunciation
which is Soviet era monument in Bulgaria
in which the inner wall is decorated
with the laborers of the World style
mural with the same burnt orange color
tones as the TVA definitely inspired the
production design of this part of the
TVA but here Loki prods the wall right
in the middle of the Sacred timeline
hourglass and the wall prunes back to
reveal several large faces of K faces
that do not have lines running down the
cheeks and now in this wider shot you
can see who is with him on the far left
that is the gray hair of Mobius and then
on the far right that it's a TBA Hunter
a guy with shorter hair who I'm pretty
sure is D90 he's the one for season one
episode two who joined B15 Squad to
Wisconsin in 1985 into the Rocks card
store in 2050 he's the one who
intimidates the evacuees and Mobius is
to lean and tell him to take it easy on
them and D90 pushes back hey
people are scared
they're about to die they should be
scared hey not a boss I actually met
Neil the actor who plays the 90 while
walking my dog in North Hollywood a
couple years ago and he's a really
really really nice dude I really hope
they bring him back for season two
remember d-90 was also the one who
showed up in the finale chasing B15 in
the Fremont Ohio high school where
rensslayer worked in 2018 when she was
known as Rebecca termine honor the Ohio
State University diploma on the wall
there Rebecca terminate was an alias of
rensslayer that she used when she joins
Victor timely in Wisconsin in 1901 in
the comics so you know it's going to be
an important detail I think rinselayer
AKA Rebecca was Victor timely so she
remains love interest wouldn't be
surprised if he's the same guy I love
interest who took his side in various
time periods before they had a falling
out and he imprisoned her in the TVA
starting her off as a hunter which would
explain why even though she lost a
pruned Loki variant silby as a young
girl who stole her temp ad rensslayer
would still be able to be promoted into
being a judge yeah someone upstairs was
making an exception for her now watching
something you love is self-care it feels
good right well with geology you can
have that good feeling of self-care in
your daily routine too geology is a 16
time award-winning personalized skincare
company recognized in men's health
Esquire and ask men grooming Awards with
over 6 000 5 Star reviews just take a
quick 30 second diagnostic quiz and
geology will create a simple and
effective skincare or hair care routine
customized just for you with ingredients
that are dermatologists tested proven to
work and personalized to your needs for
Hair Care geology's got strength in each
shampoo and conditioner co-wash which
will transform your routine and deliver
the best hair of your life it extends
the time between washes and replaces the
need for so many products so you can
wash your hair less and save money they
also offer body washes and deodorants
that are free of harsh ingredients and
they smell great and for skincare they
have you covered from all angles you can
fight acne reduce oil-ness prevent
wrinkles combat darker puffy under eyes
have smoother hydrated skin and Target
signs of aging their daily personalized
skincare routine comes with Too Faced
washes morning face cream retinol night
cream and eye cream and right now for a
limited time you can get a five piece
trial set for only 15 dollars if you use
a code rockstar70 at checkout that's
over 50 a product for just fifteen
dollars and on top of that you'll get an
additional bonus offer of one of their
brand new skin hair and body products of
your choice when you add it to your
trial to get started just click the link
in the description now this mural
imagery of the Sacred timeline is just
super interesting now on the other side
of quantumania we see here on the sacred
timeline is a Loosely woven rope of
separate timeline strands it looks even
looser than it did with Loki and Sylvie
first approach to Citadel in the Loki
season 1 finale and it hovered around
them and one thick tight ring around
that rock it was as if when he remains
constructed the TVA and pruned
everything down to a sacred timeline he
knew that inevitably that timeline would
unravel and then of course the three
time Keepers they now seem like he
remains parodies of the three that we
saw in the post-credits scene immortus
Rama Tut and Scarlet Centurion one of
them even talked with the same raspy
voice as a mortis and we know Jonathan
Majors did the voices of all three
swimming
now the second newly expanded shot shows
Loki in a fight scene using some kind of
baton to fire kind of green energy now
we see that he is fighting a TVA Hunter
this is significant Visa tells us that
Loki remains at war with the CBA perhaps
because Loki has discovered that the TVA
was founded by a Kang variant and now
Kang has militarized all the TBA against
him so in this season it looks like it's
not going to be a love hate we arrested
you but you know you can work with us to
find your even worse variant type of
relationship no there's no partnership
he and his buddy Mobius are now the
virus in the Clockwork of the dynasty
also in this wider shot we can see more
of the background behind Loki is a
wooden boat like a rowboat or maybe a
Lifeboat maybe some important boat from
history like the boat Washington use
across the Delaware or an extra Lifeboat
on the RMS Titanic this whole room with
its curved roof its rows and rows of
beams kind of looks like it's on a
vessel of some kind or like a blimp like
what kind of building interior looks
like this also To the Left Behind Loki
some other kind of old timey Machinery I
wonder if all of this is a kind of Arc
that stores important technological
Marvels throughout history like we could
see the original printing press that
published the Gutenberg Bible the gadget
the first atomic bomb that was tested at
the Trinity site in New Mexico now
actually as we're talking about the TVA
we still have so many questions about
all the technology the interfaces the
look of everything on their desks and we
have a video coming out next week here
on the new rockstars channel in which I
got to interview one of the interface
designers who created many of these
Easter eggs that you see on their
computer screens and I can tell you
there is a fascinating story behind how
and why those details were chosen hey
remind me to subscribe to our new
channel the Deep dive you can support us
by grabbing something from the deep dive
collection at nerd riot.shop you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
eavos Igbo follow new rockstars And
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
thank you